Let's revisit the CSV baseball data that we downloaded earlier.
CSV is a very popular way to store data, likely because
it's easy to read and comprehend for both humans and
computers. It also probably doesn't hurt that Microsoft Excel can export
data as a CSV. As you can see, every element
of each row is separated by a comma. If we wanted
to load this data into Pandas, we can do this
in one line. It's super easy. We simply import pandas, and
then write baseball_data equals pandas.read_csv Master.csv. This will
load the comma separated data into what Pandas calls
a data frame, where we can retrieve each
column like this, print baseball_data name first. We can
also create new columns on the data frame
by manipulating the columns in a vectorized way. For
example, if I wanted a new column that
was the sum of each player's height and weight,
called baseball_data height plus weight, I could write baseball_data
height plus weight equals baseball_data height, plus baseball_data weight.